[Music]
on today's show we have an incredible
guest pat lincione one of the most
famous consultants in the united states
he's a best-selling author we talk about
money marriages avoiding pain what's
wrong with our culture what's wrong with
everything and how to fix it stay tuned
[Music]
hey yo
what's up this is john with the dr john
baloney show hope you're doing well hope
you're healthy hope you're laughing
you've got joy in your life and if
things are hard for you right now if you
got people that are walking alongside
you so glad that you are here
this show we talk about mental health
relationships everything if you want to
be on this show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and when i say give me a
buzz really you're just going to leave a
message and kelly gets it
and
man if kelly calls you back do they feel
like they win something when you call
them
i bet they do
no
no i don't think so if you ever called
me i would feel like i won something
like hearing your voice is a joy
on the phone
not in person not when i'm in trouble
it's like a good thing i've called you
plenty of times and you you didn't
really seem like you felt like you won
something oh well just knowing my heart
i did
kelly will call you if she selects you
for the show and it will feel like you
won something i think i think i think
you will or you can go to
johndaloney.com ask fill out the form
and be on the show today
we have an incredible guest
like one of the smartest men i've ever
met one of the kindest the most generous
people you know you just meet somebody
and you just think gosh i hope i can be
like that person someday just because
they're so generous and kind and wise
and gentle and kind and hilarious and
giving and all those things
talking about pat lindsey oni and if
you've never heard that name i don't
blame you he works behind closed doors
he's got one of the most successful
consulting firms on the planet
he works with leaders he works with
people behind closed doors helping them
become better leaders helping them take
care of their businesses and the reason
i'm on the show he's a couple of reasons
number one he's written some of the most
important books i've ever read the five
dysfunctions of a team ideal team player
incredible incredible books and he
writes in a way that is accessible for
everybody that to me is the mark of a
true genius someone who can take really
complex ideas and write them he writes
in um in story and it's it's just
remarkable and he's got a new assessment
out that
was originally designed for for leaders
but has proven to really be
revolutionizing revolutionizing
marriages friendships working
partnerships all of it and so we have
them on the show today man we talk about
our cultural obsession with money
avoiding pain trust and vulnerability
what that looks like in leaders and in
people what's wrong with business and
politics and we talk about code we talk
about everything on this show talk about
it all it's a blast put in your
earphones or tell the kids to go for a
walk and listen to this one with pat
lincione
so hey
you you work with leaders all over the
country how'd you get into this like how
did this start that's a great question i
was a kid
i i i didn't know it at the time but i
was a kid and my dad would come home
from work and say and he'd complain
about work i didn't know what work was
and then he'd talk about his manager i
don't know what a manager was but it
wasn't good and i remember thinking
that's dumb
you know i like my dad i love my dad i
don't want him to be like that i didn't
like that he felt that way
and i remember as a kid that was always
planted a seed in my head then i i went
to college and i we were relatively poor
and so i needed to get a good job and a
management consulting firm said hi and i
thought management and consulting that's
exactly what this is it had nothing to
do with that was all number crunching so
i struggled for two years but then i
that i got my first view at business and
then i said okay i'm interested in that
that human part of this work
and so i it wasn't really a field for it
no it didn't exist no and so i started
doing things and pursuing that and uh
the next thing you know i was you know
thinking do i go to work steve jobs
offered me a job to work at pixar oh wow
and then eric schmidt offered me a job
to work at um novell at the time
and i was like no no no i love i love
this field so me and a few colleagues
started a company
24 years ago and said let's help
all companies get healthier
and
we didn't have many books or anything
like that we're just going to go out and
consult
and by the grace of god and
that and true north of like i really
want people to enjoy and be dignified in
their work
that's how this came about
i don't have a graduate degree in
anything yeah
um but you've got a hundred thousand
hours sitting knee to knee with people
right right right and and i almost went
to graduate school a few times but there
was not really uh like for one program
for that exactly and i was like i think
that i'll just be back here trying to
get this job again so that's kind of how
it all worked wow
and so if you look at the arc of
business leadership and health over the
last 24 years
till now
where are we
um well like so many things it's
i think it's kind of bifurcated i think
there's some really healthy leaders and
companies out there and there's some
really unhealthy ones
and i think that uh a lot of young
people have now grown up seeing a lot of
these silicon valley leaders who are
what i call
selfish you know self-oriented they're
reward-centered like what do i get out
of this gotcha and so they watch the you
know what's the movie about
social social networks
and they're like yeah that's the way
that's what a leader is
and they see all these things so i think
there's a bifurcation there's those
people in the world that are like no i
gotta i gotta be a humble leader i gotta
serve these people i work with servant
leadership which is the only kind but
then there's others that see watch tv
and see the famous ones and go hey it's
all about being cool and pretty rich
so i think there's a real bifurcation
and it's it's a battle you know i i want
people to realize if you're not a sermon
leader you're not a leader at all so
that's what there is why why
why
you've worked with them i've worked with
them for years
why
it seems like you can tell people all
day long that money doesn't make you
happy
enough of it does let's be honest having
money is better than i have money
but it doesn't solve the hole in you
and it
you cannot tell somebody that you
literally have to experience it and then
say i'll see you when you get back
yeah i i i don't know that's the one
thing i can tell somebody don't do drugs
and they eventually are like go have fun
with your life cocaine will ruin your
life right and eventually
i i buy that or hey don't do this i
but money that conversation is the one
that i can't seem i've never been able
to break through to myself to anybody
around me it seems to be this carrot
that's always moving yeah and i suppose
for some people it depends on how much
money they need in order to realize that
ah okay like some people need like oh i
become i made this much money and i have
a nice hi and this doesn't make me happy
i think this is the wrong path
like like mike singletary was the coach
of the 49ers years ago and uh he he was
a football player oh yeah and he and he
used to wear a cross and they'd say why
do you wear the cross have you always
done that he goes no no i i started
doing this after my team won the super
bowl and they said what do you mean he
goes because after we won i wasn't happy
and i realized
that's why
so he needed to win super bowl to
realize it wasn't about winning and fame
and all that other kind of stuff and
maybe somebody makes their first million
dollars for another person they might
have to make a hundred million dollars
some of these guys have have made
billions of dollars i don't know what
jeff bezos lives for and they're still
chasing it yeah yeah it's going to outer
space yeah to me it's just a drug yeah
it just he's just every person i've ever
worked with by closed doors is it's it's
a drug yeah and whether it's it's and
it's a small scale like whether it's
another publication or in my nerd world
or this or that it just keeps moving and
moving right hey you know a great quote
i think it was saint augustine who said
whether a bird is tied down by a chain
or a string it doesn't matter because it
still can't fly
so whether it's pornography and
prostitution and cocaine or money and
fame and
and and and that it to me it doesn't
work being the
biggest baddest associate director of
the mail room no it absolutely matters
right
absolutely you make your kingdom the the
wherever you happen to be placed it ends
in ash every time every time every time
i wish there was a prophylactic which
was a way we could get upstream and tell
i could tell my son that and it just
seems to that seems to be the drug man
well and i try to do to tell my sons and
other young people i'm like listen
so i've done
better than i ever thought i'd do in my
life yeah but i realized years ago this
doesn't matter absolutely and let me
tell you when sometimes people recognize
me so i'm not like a famous guy but
sometimes i'll be some place my kids
will see me people talk to me and i'll
go just so you know that doesn't matter
feed me
exactly
you might think that's cool yeah
but i used to think it would be and then
i realized you can never get enough of
it right that's a that's a false
it was when i was in the bathroom at a
urinal and somebody came in and started
talking
hey i was like that's kind of weird
and i was new to it so i'm trying to be
kind and then they said hey man let me
ask you something and i realized oh
we're going to do counseling here like
why
like this didn't happen you know i mean
that's what i realized this is not it's
different now the opportunity to help
people is ex yes it's it's incredible
that's the gift and if you weren't on
the beca but because you're sitting here
and there's a camera here and there's
and people know about that that doesn't
make it different no that's right and
i'd rather be living someplace where
people didn't know me and i was doing
something that god intended me to do and
i was a good person and i knew and i had
faith
that's that person is more successful
than a famous person who looks happy
when they're on tv and then it goes home
and feels empty yeah and i try to scare
the hell out of people yeah
so how how has
give me a insight in the last 24 months
36 months
you've been business has been on fire
right or and
somebody asked me they did an interview
they were asking me about you know you
know what's given all these kids anxiety
was it the mask or not and i said i
think what's driving childhood anxiety
right now
is that we've got millions and millions
and millions of people telling them
rightly or wrongly that your teachers
want to kill you and your churches are
failing you and you're in the we're
terrified it feels like our bedrock
institutions have cracks in them and
maybe they always have and we're just
not seeing them for the first time
i've
been at two different businesses on this
on the front end of this and
it feels like things are doing this
how are
business leaders behind closed doors
handling this stuff are is it smooth
sailing are they
is it exciting or is it terrifying and
then you just like you're a dad you got
two kids you got kids you got your
husband i mean how are you handling that
i mean just so in case my kids listen to
this which they want i have four oh four
two of them hey what about us yeah no no
no he specifically said he doesn't care
about you too guys
you know you know what i think
i think that first of all it's not
exciting or terrifying it's sad
i think what's happening is people are
wondering
if life has meaning
and see and the blessing in this is this
your gpa was never your meaning
your
your the college you went to and getting
that sticker on your thing was never
meaning but it was we were punting that
ball down the kicking that can down the
street now it's awful certain like it's
like oh yeah the school doesn't care if
we
we're not going to play a sport this you
know whatever or we're closing this down
or the church doesn't think churches
that or whatever else and people are
like going well i was just kind of
living for and it's like it's making
people actually go
what is the meaning
and so i think it's just brought
everybody up to the edge of the cliff
and
it's a good thing when it brings you to
your knees and you go oh okay i mean for
me i'm a person of faith of jesus and
and it's like okay that he's all that
matters that's all i got anyway that's
all i had before but when i had you know
my soror my i'm not sure my fraternity
or my college or my lacrosse season or
football or this or my job
those were distractions that made me
think life is okay and now that when
those grind to a halt
i think these kids are like so none of
this matters
so so this is all and the thing is they
were going to come to that conclusion
where they did their senior year of
college or two years after yeah or 20
years down the road when their spouse
drops dead yeah yeah it happens yeah and
all that stuff i thought i was living
for it is actually not that real
but and so it's this can be a really
wonderful thing
but for many where they don't know where
to turn it's the worst thing yeah
what about
i'm talking to you as just as a
colleague now those of
my friends that work all over the
country behind closed doors with people
whether they're people in the margins
the
or they are
the top of the top of the top one
percent
the folks who are working with those
folks
i'm i'm hearing a level of exhaustion
that i've never heard before a level of
frustration and
oh oh
this close to despair in the helping
profession yes and so i'm talking to you
as a colleague there like as a guy who's
just been behind closed doors man how
are you
well i um
it's this
since this all the last two and a half
years been the time of the greatest
healing in my life okay that's
incredible but that
by the grace of god i started seeing
somebody yeah a few couple few years ago
wow a faith-based therapist guy and came
to realize that uh
that there were wounds i didn't even
know about and they were actually
propelling me to work harder and be more
successful but they weren't satisfying
me that was my prostitute pornography
whatever else
and so it's been during the same time
this has been a horrible wonderful
frightening painful
healing fantastic time
i think that's how it usually goes
and i think that maybe for people
who don't understand that there's a
purpose to suffering these last two
years have been just all bad
but if it if it woke us up to
appreciating our spouse or our kids or
certainly our faith and and little
things more then then that can be a
great blessing but if all of our uh
stock was put into our career and our
social life and everything else and all
that gets taken away and that's all
there is it is absolutely terrifying
i
and it partly was for me too but i was
luckily i was exploring that at the same
time yeah do you mind digging into that
no not at all what um because that's the
same drug i am addicted to yeah yeah
yeah tell me about that well i like
being with a good trauma therapist would
say oh that's not trauma and like no
that is and who's able to connect this
dot to this dot to this dot and suddenly
you're like oh this is the story man i'm
running a script i'm not i'm the most
unoriginal idiot in this and i think i'm
so cutting edge
no man you know what i mean absolutely
you know i
that this therapist told me two days ago
because i'm always worried like i don't
want to be proud i don't want to be
prideful and he said you're not you're
wounded and you're shameful uh you're
afraid you're going to fail
and let people down
and that's what's driving you not that
you think you're important because you
don't think you're important at all
and i was like i'm relieved to know it's
not pride shame sucks though yeah
there's a great theologian that rich
mullen says that
often people of faith
can be as proud of the things they don't
have as those who aren't are of the
things they do have
so you can pull up in your your 1976
corolla next to this guy's lexus and be
like i would never spend money on that
and you're the same person all of a
sudden right you know i i once heard
somebody right yeah i some i heard
somebody once say that some saints said
humility is being able to look at a
cathedral and be proud of it as though
you had built it yourself huh as opposed
to going oh i could have never done that
that's just such a loser yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so but so for me though it was
growing up thinking that my achievements
were going to uh earn me
um the love i was looking for yeah and i
did they just never do and so you just
keep going i i didn't understand that it
was love i thought i was chasing favor
and it wasn't until i realized no
beneath favor doesn't a lot of people
tell you they like you and they actually
do they actually do like you it's
something deeper than that that's really
interesting because i said love and i
even hesitated
but you're right favor is what you think
you want yes but i mean like i got
plenty of favor now and it's not filling
that hole that's right
and and granted my mom and dad god bless
them
um
weren't able to fill it but but some of
that can't even be filled by your
parents no that's right now they there
were things that i didn't get when i was
young and who they were they had their
own issues but it was real yeah but
ultimately and again as a follower of
jesus ultimately i need to know god
loves me no matter what i do no matter
what i don't do
and then that's going to let me perform
not from a place of fear and shame but
from a place of gratitude and service
yeah service yeah what's what's one
thing that you've adopted that's been
helpful
well
something i adopted uh 13 days ago it's
been very helpful fantastic i did an
anti-new year's resolution that is you
know new year's resolutions about
resolve willfulness i'm going to do this
loses and every day i wake up now and i
really try to just sit and go whatever
you have for me god
god when we say god's will god's will be
done it's like i don't care i i have a
day planned but i don't know what i'm
supposed to do whatever you put in front
of me if there's a person that needs me
or if there's something you call me to
do or if something goes wrong at home
and i'm supposed to be there for that
let me embrace that
and that has been 13 days and it's a
difference maker i've i've
yeah that'll change it from the inside
out right and i need it it's an
untethering right oh my gosh this
surrender detachment
submission all that and it's like and
i've been saying it you know your will
be done
it's like no that means my will is not
willfulness is a problem right even
though our society says be willful
overcome things it's like well work hard
do your best but if whatever he has for
you you want to seek that and embrace
that i can't say i would do in that my
life i'd be like yeah your will be done
as long as it involves me
making this much money and getting this
many clients and yeah yeah yeah
huh that's hard it it's a daily thing i
have a new day resolution every day
and i don't even never heard of that it
might be every half day yeah i mean i
don't know how long we can go before
having to remind ourselves of things but
it's certainly not once a year and so
every day i have to remember and i'm
sure that like i get halfway through the
day and i'm like well crap here i go i'm
doing my thing
yeah so it's i it's a constant constant
thing and it will never be done and i
just hope i'd never stop doing it yeah
and it gets me through when things get
disappointing i you know john you know
this better than i do i think this whole
idea of sadness and disappointment being
something we're supposed to run from oh
man
you're going to get me all my soapbox i
was earlier i i don't even know that
achievements
or
i
i think our addictions and we look at
them we
like whether they're drugs or money or
achievement or whatever working 90 hours
a week
i think that our addiction is to not
feeling bad yes absolutely and we have
pathologized any sort of
bad feeling and if you know folks and
i'll top my head i just lost it there's
a disease where you actually lose pain
sensory we were just talking about
people die yeah early
right because they can't get the normal
signals that their body's trying to tell
them that this isn't this is this is not
safe for us
and when we try to go through life
avoiding any discomfort then suddenly
you get like we're talking about earlier
off air with your kid like what you just
said makes me uncomfortable and now i
have to ruin your life because that's
the only thing i could do to keep my
life from being less uncomfortable right
i think that's so profound we're
obsessed with
avoiding discomfort yep
absolutely and uh and the whole idea of
that suffering has a re a reason and
that it's i like to ask this question to
people i say would you rather go through
life worrying all the time and then
never having any things you're worried
about happening happen
or go through life not worrying but then
have some bad things happen to you
everybody says the second always and yet
we are so and this is what my problem is
i'm always on high alert for trying to
avoid anything that's going to cause me
pain suffering disappointment or sadness
yeah or worse yet for my children yeah
that's that that's usually childhood
based
it's completely henry cloud i is a
friend and yeah he said one day this is
what got me to go to counseling two and
a half years ago he said pat you got
some childhood wounds there you got it
okay there you go yeah and i did and
that's what's been going on two and a
half years oh i've been i've been on
duty trying to avoid problems and solve
problems and avoid feeling yeah for even
before i read the book i remember seeing
the title of
vander cook's the body keeps the score
and the the the title was convicting
even before i read it and it's a
masterpiece before i read it i remember
thinking
oh
being on high alert 24 7 for 20 years 30
years 40 years
i'm gonna die young my body's gonna say
okay i put my time in that's all i got
right right right man there's a cost to
that so go so a an addiction to
man i had a question here i was going to
ask you that
an addiction to not
feeling uncomfortable not recognizing
that discomfort pain that's part of any
sort of growth process period if you
have an abscess you have to have surgery
you have to be cut open literally
part of healing always involves pain
part of growing always involves pain
and then i juxtapose that with what's
happening in the working world right now
and you're much more in tune than i am
um
it appears that there is a
it may have been bubbling for years and
years but a interruption of employers
versus employees
this sense of you
owe me
i deserve it should be like
fill in the blank and you can make that
up wherever whatever wherever you
industry happen to work in wherever you
happen to be living in the country those
things are different
but there's the sense that i should get
the job i want and it should be
a track should be laid out for me and
all of my care should be taken care of
either by my workplace or my government
and so i just need to get in the right
seat i did all the right things
and that's not reality
you know what i mean and then there's
this also this push back like i don't
owe you anything i don't even have to
treat you like a human i don't have to
serve anybody i'm the leader you there's
this weird collision it feels like it's
all coming undone now people are just
saying you know what i'm out you know
it's interesting like in a personal
relationship in marriage
the idea is oh no i want to overstep in
terms of my grace for you and and that
other person oversteps in their grace
for them and then it this is beautiful
yep
and
today we have this but in a marriage
when there's like no i need my 50 i need
my i'm not getting mine then it falls
apart and that's what's going on in
society today it used to be like no
serve your employer and the employers
are like no you got to honor your
employees
and i think that because we do have this
and i hate using that this word although
i mean it's the right word but i don't
know where it comes from entitlement
there's a lot of people out there that
think that they're owed something
i don't know i mean i'm not i see i see
it on both sides of the ledge oh yeah i
see my buddies who are leaders like they
should be doing this and i think
they don't have to man like
you know and the other side of it is
that same like my boss should be giving
me this and this and this and
it's i think everybody it's like a 360
degree entitlement well what's
interesting though i mean and this is
we're just talking about this now is but
that that
manager
is both a manager so so for the ceo and
the line employee okay that's the purity
right but what about the manager of
these line employees or them they're
both they're on both ends
they're serving both both sides of the
fence right and so so what's happened to
the just the general attitude
of why people are feeling like that and
i think it's that's where i think it
gets that institutional trust
and i do think that there's that that uh
gosh i don't know the answer to this
this is a fascinating conversation i i i
i i'm making this up here i'm
spitballing it the only thing i can
think of is
the radical movement in the last 25 30
50 years
uh
publicly traded companies that we are no
i i think dave does something good here
is he consistently
puts the customer in front of us and
says here is susan from des moines
we
changed her life
not look how much money we made look how
much money we made and it it i think
when you pull yourself apart from who
you're serving in what your product is
even doing and it's just about how much
money can i make
over time it goes back to that
conversation we have a minute ago about
that never it never fills it up right
service always does yeah you know it's
so interesting i will tell you
throughout my career i've always
really felt bad about companies
merging and getting huge yes because
human beings are meant to have a
relationship with their customers
relationship with their managers and
with the leaders of their firms and so
the fact that they um
that people feel so distant from their
from their organizations
and uh
and so i think that you're right
i think publicly traded companies when
companies ipo
it's all i'm always like my condolences
because your life is about to get
appreciably worse yeah
and and frankly so is the customer yeah
everybody loses i don't know maybe they
don't and again no they feel ignorant on
business they do yeah
the only reason the company should go
public
is because they need the capital because
of it's it's in a capital intensive
business gotcha you know i mean there's
some so you have to get capital but so
much of the if you talk to most people
they're ipo because they want a
short-term payout yeah i want to make
money now i can and i get it that's the
economics of it but man does is it not a
good thing for the working world for the
for the culture
and and what i've what i'm really
disappointed in right now john is that
in this time in the last two years the
companies that are paying the price for
all this
government bs
are the small and medium-sized ones
the big ones are making out like bandits
have you seen the split
yeah the wealth generation over the last
24 months has been astounding yeah and
it's been astounding and there is a
different you know we talk about left or
right or all these kind of things
there's an elite culture now yeah
and rather than
middle-class
medium-sized real people
you know subsidiary out working serving
the poor
running a business that's how a good
society works you have to have that
right now we are creating more people
that are unemployed some of which just
decide it's just not worth it to work
that's terrible right and then we have
these huge companies that seem immune
from the from the
the problems in society because they
have sweetheart deals with the
government everything yeah and it this
is a really bad thing it's happened
throughout history but i can't believe
it's happening in my lifetime again
in the the the magic word there is again
like we know this
i feel like it's a guy who
responded to that text from somebody at
work and got himself in trouble and then
he healed his marriage him and his
spouse went to counseling and then 10
years later somebody texts him
and he responds again and you know where
this goes man i know it
so
you know
thing
there's always hope
we have to be realistic oh yeah yeah
yeah but but we have to be realists
about what we see is wrong yeah but one
the one thing i've learned is that i
don't want to either give in yep or get
bitter yeah see that's the thing
i think that either one of those is such
a flex if you meet somebody who's
who is clear-eyed
and says
i'm gonna do what i can tomorrow right
but but caving to a culture that you
know is going the wrong direction and
then it's creating all this is terrible
right but then getting so bitter that it
ruins your ability to take a walk with
your dog or your wife yeah your husband
that's bad too and so it to me i've been
driven to on my knees to pray there you
go and it's like this the best huh all
right hey we'll be right back on the dr
john dillon show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right let's get into some i want to
can we do like a i want to do a rapid
fire i don't get to talk to super
great leadership minds a lot okay well
you're not today either but i'm gonna do
my best help me
with how a leader can do
both
or feelings and strength and power and
humility a leader's got to
there's
here's what i'm getting at
there is a culture of feelings run
everything
however i feel runs my day my work
whatever and everyone around me needs to
be in service to how i feel
and there's also the movement which is
you know screw your feelings nothing
matters just plow on you know drag it
kill it whatever
there's a
reality in between those two which is
yeah your feelings happen and you still
got to go about doing what's right or
doing what's necessary etc how does a
leader and that could be a
parent that can be a teacher that can be
a ceo
somebody on their neighborhood watch i
don't care
how do you balance strength and
vulnerability strength and humility and
power how do you balance that stuff well
i love this question now and i like how
you explain it to me because
we are not meant to not be feeling i
think about it as parents yeah like if i
present myself to my kids that i never
have doubt i'm never wrong i'm never
sorry i'm i'm never sad
which is a a lot of parents can do that
that doesn't make sense destroy your
children yes
and uh
at the same time if i wake up every day
and feel like you're responsible for my
feelings my sadness and everything else
and and those are the two extremes now
most of us think the first one is
actually pretty good though
like kids i'm fine
and and that's not i mean i kind of grew
up in an environment like that my dad
was like that and i didn't understand
what vulnerability was
and so i think the thing is we have to
say hey listen first and foremost i'm
here to serve you i'm your leader i'm
your parent i'm your whatever
i'm your coach
i am here for you yeah but i also have
legitimate valid feelings that i will
share with you
because that's going to make you a
better person to understand that i'm
human and to play the role of helping me
too sometimes that's right
i mean kids need to know they can
support their parents employees need to
know that they can speak truth to their
boss
athletes on a team need to know that
they can help their coach
whether it's in coaching or in life or
whatever it is and to deprive them of
that is not a gift right
so but the ques the question we have to
know though is when in doubt it when in
doubt it needs to lean toward the
service to others as a parent my
feelings have to be just a little less
important than those of my kids but if i
try to do that for too long they're
going to pay the price for it i've done
that wrong for years
i thought my job was to prevent them
from suffering
and then it it wound me up and then it
caused suffering for them that i didn't
even know was causing him yeah which is
hard to admit but so many parents i
talked to can relate to that so i got a
i got a call from
um somebody who i've known for years
who's
long story short that has a child who's
getting in trouble
with the law and said hey i could get a
lawyer and do this and do this and do
this and maybe get them off whatever
i said are you interested in solving
this problem today or you're gonna help
this child become
a healthy adult i said because if you're
gonna help me a healthy adult then you
say i'm like i can't get you out of this
but i'll hold your hand in the process
and i'll go to court with you and hold
your hand and when you get taken away
i'll be the last hug you like that was
and then they'll do their time and then
we'll go about you know i mean that to
me was the
though we're playing a long game with
their kids right right but that and so i
can say this with fairly high confidence
the difficulty of making the right
decision there is because we're caring
about ourselves that's right yeah
because if i go so my son has to go to
prison or to go to jail or go to
juvenile hall or get in trouble it could
be smaller than that too
what does that say about me that's going
to be hard for me
i'll i'd like to help them get out i'm
going to be uncomfortable yes
and i and you don't even completely
realize at the time yeah but if you can
the most self-less thing to do for them
is to give them what they need even if
it doesn't give you what you need
because i want to know that i'm being a
good parent i want to know that they're
they're they're they're happy right now
yeah yeah and they're going to be
happier when you get them out of trouble
thanks dad that was great and you're
like oh yeah they're they're happy with
me i've just kicked that can down the
street
yeah and then when they're moving back
in with you or they're asking for a loan
yeah exactly yeah yeah all right so
leaders in vulnerability how does that
work
you know
it's one of the most important things
like so in the five dysfunction of the
team trust is at the bottom of the
pyramid right i mean you have to build
trust on team and the leader has to go
first and you cannot build trust with
another person if you are not
vulnerable and vulnerability is a
powerful thing but it has to be real
and false vulnerability is more
dangerous than not it's gross man it is
it's just like humility is great gross
false humility
is is great anytime somebody says hey
watch this you're going to cry i'm oh
i'm done with you yeah yeah yeah
and then it's performative yeah exactly
oh so so vulnerable genuine
vulnerability which always
is uncomfortable yes
if you're being vulnerable as a leader
and you're like no i'm very comfortable
with this it's not vulnerable that's not
false because vulnerable gets killed
right that's that's the whole thing
right really up yeah exactly
the the in latin it's it's it's
liable to attack
gosh what is that i can't remember the
the root of the word vulnerability but
the point is
every leader has to be vulnerable but
when they they go too far
and they they're using it as as therapy
yeah that can be very dangerous too yeah
and so it's one of those
um
it's one of those maturity things it's
like parenting though no leader is
immune to this there is no leader that
never did that yeah
and there's no leader that's never
probably been falsely vulnerable we
don't have and i'll say politically
i think that may be the single
missing element
is a leader saying
i thought this and i was wrong so here's
what i'm going to do
if somebody would do that i think it
would galvanize people in a way that
that you couldn't even plot on a chart
in a graph i do not under maybe it's
maybe it's this john maybe it's the kind
of person that wants that job
does not have that that
skill or that capability because the
kind of person that would be willing to
do that would never do the things you
need to do to get that job that's but i
don't know why people just don't say
because i mean i've done it yeah i have
two hey i whiffed on that yeah
most people will say a coach that comes
off the field at the end of the game
goes i made a hugely bad call there yeah
and we lost because of me people are
like that guy's awesome follow that guy
yeah yeah but somehow in politics
it's bizarre
yeah you know what i mean it's but it's
bizarre i think they're being advised by
people that
i don't know it's it's such an
adversarial activity i suppose it's like
a lawyer though i i guess if you went to
trial not too many lawyers would go hey
i said this thing yesterday i think you
should disregard it because i realized
that wasn't fair oh yeah and i think
when you have an adversarial
relationship now but the problem is
that's why politics is not leadership
politics is gamesmanship
and true leadership two too few
politicians are really leaders
and i've met a few that are yeah they
usually don't get anywhere near the top
huh because they're not playing they're
not playing and if you're if you're
competing with somebody who's playing by
a different set of rules and you tie you
tie one hand behind your back because
you want to be that way they're going to
go that's great i'm just going to cut
your arm out you'll lose every time yeah
so it's an unfortunate thing i don't
know if it's always been that way i
don't i think media makes it worse
absolutely um but i i do wish we had
leaders in leadership yeah would that be
so nice all right what about leaders and
mental health
well this is my this is my the thing
that's most interesting to me right now
is that so many leaders are leading from
their wounds
and they don't even know that
they actually see
their wounds as their strength
i mean i did this for years you know i
was achieving and at high standards and
worked hard and i thought well see i'm a
hard-working guy and it's like oh no
you're terrified of failing huh
and that doesn't mean you can't heal
those wounds and still be a great leader
in fact you'll be a much better leader
and so i think that uh
i think mental health of the leader is
critical how do you balance that
humility with ambition
because it feels like a teeter-totter
and what i see people is
they'll go they'll be making their money
they'll be doing a good job they'll go
to their spiritual retreat and they'll
be like oh i'm going to quit everything
and go work at whole foods and or you
have the other side that's just pounding
the pavement over and over
and there's got to be a balance between
no go like work hard and do good things
that help a lot of people
and no it's not going to i don't know
what's the balance there well it's so
funny i wrote an article
23 years ago yeah
um and it was called the trouble with
humility and it's this teeter-totter and
it's like here's how i look at and i
don't know if this answers a question
but i just have to tell this story
and it's like humility is i think that
i'm no more important than the people
that i lead
okay right that's really important to
know you're not that you're not a more
important person
but
my ac my actions
are more impactful
than those of the people i leave people
are watching me and that's truth that's
just true truth that's right and most
people can't hold both of those things
in mind at the same time i worked with a
guy who was a really humble leader and
i'd say mark you got to get out there
and talk he'd go why do i why do they
care what i think
and then other people that are like hey
i got out there and i inspired people
and then it's like
i must be pretty important uh i'm more
important than them so you have to break
that in the middle and go my actions
actually are that stewardship you know
that's really but i'm i'm not that
important that's a tough thing to do
both of those i used to tell my staff at
the universities i worked at
if i didn't come to work for two weeks
as the senior student affairs officer if
i didn't come to work for two weeks
a couple of you all would know
if the person cleaning the bathrooms
doesn't come for two weeks this place
stops spinning period right let's be
real clear about who's the most
important in this building right now
right now you can never lose that but as
the leader you know what was really
important that you were telling them
that oh yeah yeah you know what i mean
so that was really important that you're
so you have to do both of those things
that's right yes and um and then you got
to live it right i got to make sure that
we are honoring the the folks that are
left in the margins at that workplace
right oh my god that's that and i've got
to i've got to go first and whether i'm
a parent or a dad you want i i did an
internship with a or with a psychologist
and i was asking him a question about
hey how do i how do i tell my son to
respect women and he said respect he's
like yeah treat your wife right it was
like it's like you can tell anything you
want he's just going to watch you but
what would be another way yeah
yeah not that way yeah it was a very
simple i was with my 15 year old this
the other day we were in a long drive
and i said hey you know i love mom right
and he was like oh yeah i said because
you know sometimes we don't say the
night sometimes i don't treat her the
right way and she might not she might be
unhappy with me but you know we're in
love with each other and she's wonderful
and because
i don't know i never heard my dad say
that yeah yeah and i needed it yeah and
and god bless him and my mom but
but we we have to model that and it's i
think parents we don't understand that
our kids anchor
everything into that sentiment yeah
are those two people stable and safe
and if they are the kids will swing off
and repel off and do wild things
and if they aren't they will swing off
and do wild things but they'll let go
you know they let go and you know if uh
if people are listening to this and they
haven't done that very well in the past
you can just do it right now and trust
god that it's gonna be fine well it's
that's vulnerability which is you know i
had a guest on a few weeks ago and we're
talking about
is is vulnerability or is it humility
it almost
rests on a bedrock of as you put in the
book it's just being trustworthy being
honest saying i've been telling you this
and i was wrong right this is the right
way to do this or do you know how i
treated mom for a few years there not
good bad not good
and are you going to watch me do better
right yeah
because i know when people hear things
like this it's easy to go oh i didn't do
that well and it's like no start now
what's that old adage what's the best
time to plant a tree 10 years ago yeah
exactly or today second second best is
today that's right yeah all right um
tell me about a time you've been wrong
well there's there are many just one
okay i mean
so there's big ones and little ones i
want a big one for you what's the most
public wrong
if you could go back 10 years 20 years
you'd go uh i'd say that one i'd say
this differently
well i'll tell you an anecdotal one
because i didn't know this
one i mean i wrote a book yeah and i i
had the best title for the book and i i
we did use that title it's called the
three signs of a miserable job
because it was the right title people
would like that you know the five
dysfunctions of a team they liked the
fact that it was kind of like
dysfunction what's that about so i said
there's got to be the three signs of a
miserable job
we published the book with that title
nobody would take it to work
[ __ ] about a because move and so i was
like
that was my call yeah it sucked yeah
so we retitled it the three signs i mean
the the um the truth about employee
engagement oh but that's that's the easy
one yeah gosh hey that's an easy one
that's a big one i just went through the
titling process for my new book and it
that was the thing i i wanted to call it
something and the head of publishing
here preston he's a saint he said
nobody will carry that book nobody will
walk up to the counter and buy that book
with that title on it no one's going to
carry that book around with them because
it's indicting on that and i was like oh
man i didn't think about that that would
be a good article yeah but not a good
book that's right so that's one gosh i
make a lot i wish my wife were here um
and my staff she actually wrote in and
i'm just kidding yeah i mean that was
good that was good that's okay okay um
what's the time you changed your mind
um
so my wife has been telling me we needed
to leave california for a long time
and for the longest time it was like
adversarial i was like no no no no no
and then i finally realized you're right
for our future we need to do that so i
had to say
your instincts on that and your your
your passion around that is correct so
we're in the process of doing that
yeah yeah we're going to be neighbors
i'm excited yeah oh man um
we have a path we have an
aversion to changing your mind and as a
guy who spent the last 20 years in in
working with scientists in the academy
that's
it struck me and you and i may have we
may have talked about this offline
the
when when let's say with the covet stuff
when when kings caught things kings
college whatever it was laid out their
first model
and said we think this many millions and
millions and millions people are going
to pass away every scientist who was in
that world
said
fantastic game on because the whole
thing is peer review and iron sharpens
iron i think you're wrong and this is
why and i think you're wrong and then
within a few weeks it had been revised
way down and then in a few weeks
and the whole process has been about how
can we be a little bit less wrong today
that's that's how scientists work
and i just joined this team here in a
media company
and i realized oh there's two places
where you can't say i changed my mind
media and politics well science is now
that one of those things they're oh
they're getting there well that's just
become politicized did you hear what
aaron rodger aaron rodgers said if you
can't disagree that's not science i mean
it's like found that's the science is
the pursuit of truth through
disagreement that's it that's the whole
enterprise they canceled him
they said they delivered they said
you're not we're de-platforming you on
this and it's like no no that was that's
just the definition that's it that's it
so so but the problem you're right they
politicize science yes yeah cause like
right now we should be going like this
okay and i can't believe i'm gonna say
this out loud everybody the people that
developed said the vaccines do not
prevent people from getting or spraying
the disease now right that's okay that's
we're not we learned we learned yes and
so therefore
um we need to take a different approach
yes but so many people are like no no no
but we already dug in on that we have to
continue and it's like no you're losing
credibility
by the by the
moment the credibility that
that goes back to yeah but that is
politics when you lose credibility yeah
and it's it's that just double down
right right
we could talk about that all day truth
truth has to be
society breaks down when there is no
longer concern for truth but that i get
to spin it this way or or might doesn't
make right truth makes right one of my
favorite things sounds so
counterintuitive my favorite things to
do is to be
found wrong oh my gosh like hey you're
because i got a better way to do it oh i
i think one thing i think i'm pretty
when i argue with my staff at work the
moment cody or somebody says something
that's a lot smarter i like to go oh my
gosh that's so much better yeah or i'll
go to work and they'll say that's not
what you said yesterday and i'm like
you're probably right but whatever i
said yesterday i was wrong i was wrong
yeah yeah i'm right that's liberating
it's it's such a free way to walk
through the world yeah yeah i love it
okay uh favorite book
oh gosh there's many
my favorite fiction book is by is by uh
dean koontz he's a great author people
don't know he's a very he was like back
in the day he was like uh it was an
alternative to stephen king back in the
day yes yeah and the difference is king
writes about really dark things
coons is a is a closet um it's all about
hope and
truth and you might not i didn't know
that oh yeah and he has a book called
brother odd okay which is one of my
favorite books it's this odd thomas
series put that on my on my list um you
know i you got to say the bible because
it but it's not a book it's it's more
it's many books so that's a and um is
there another book i have this little
book by a guy named father jacques
philippe it's this little pink book it's
called the
the building and maintaining of peace oh
wow and it's like a mate the guy is like
where do you get that where'd you get
this
but anyway so that's that's my favorite
little book i give it a favorite band of
all time
um that would probably be
queen
really not growing up yeah when i was a
girl grew up we thought they were odd
yeah now i listen to their music who's
ever done music this is incredible yeah
they are phenomenal phenomenal the
eagles would be close and
yeah dave loves the eagles yeah
okay so
before we wrap up here
let's walk me through this so you've got
this magical new assessment
that's incredible i took it
and
dude this thing
i hate getting nailed to the wall it
makes me uncomfortable i do like being
found out that i'm wrong
i don't like it when i don't realize i'm
not a snowflake and somebody i've never
met says no this is kind of how you
operate and i'm like oh man okay so tell
me about this genius working genius
assessment gosh and now that it's so
interesting because it tells me a lot it
makes sense given what you did before in
colleges in universities and and who you
are on this show so the working genius
is this there there are six
required skills to get anything done in
life okay
any kind of project running a company
running your family organizing family
vacation running into church anything
any
kind of work
involves six different skills okay
and every person two of those are what
we call your working genius
they give you joy and energy it's a gift
from god you're naturally good at you
enjoy you can do it all day long and
you're not going to burn out awesome two
of them are on the other end of the
scale that
doing it for any length of time
drains you of your joy and energy it
just it's like i was not meant to do
this and then two are kind of in the
middle you're pretty good at it but it
doesn't feed you okay but you can get by
okay so it's called you're working
genius you're working frustration and
then in the middle of your working
competency does this work at home too oh
absolutely okay in your marriage my wife
and i had a huge breakthrough
because we realized but we had similar
deficiencies
so both of us were constantly looking at
each other why don't you do that why
don't you do that how come you haven't
gotten on that yeah we're like we both
hate that oh okay we didn't have
language for it gotcha okay so we this
came out about a year ago and a quarter
almost a quarter of a million people
have taken yeah dude that's so sad it's
all over the place the stories we're
hearing from people yeah
we one guy called he said i thought my
wife hated me hmm you would love this
yeah and i and he and we said what do
you mean he laughed he goes really i
thought he was pretty down on me because
i had the the genius of invention that's
one of the six geniuses
which means i love to come up with new
ideas i'm a fountain of new ideas at
home and everywhere
she has the genius of discernment which
is evaluating ideas and giving people
feedback well that wouldn't work or this
would work better maybe you should tweak
it like that
he thought she was just against all of
his ideas like she was like
raining on his parade every day
and they literally did this on their
anniversary and she said honey my gift
is discernment i'm loving you when i do
that i didn't i don't want you to feel
like i'm against you i'm for you and
they said it changed their marriage
huh which is crazy so that she was
trying to love him
in the way that she knows how right and
he and truthfully he probably wanted her
to go
that's a great idea honey let's do and
she was like no no here's what's not
going to work about that oh god so
anyway that's just one little example i
love it i love it okay so who am i
you're so there's you have the first
genius your first genius is the one
that's at 50 000 feet which is the
genius of wonder okay which means you
can ponder things and contemplate things
and sit with like big ideas you know
that's comfortable for you yeah
and that's like the the highest 50 000
foot head in the clouds level you're
like what is this that's where all this
comes from
now what's interesting is your second
genius is enablement
enablement is the ability to come
alongside someone and support them in
what they need uh
right that's the old professor in me huh
well yeah and and it's that you were you
you also were working with these teams
that you supported these kids yeah yeah
so you could see their needs and go i
know what you need yeah so you are at
the highest level a wonder this is a
relatively
um
rare type not completely but relatively
rare you're the idealistic
supporter
like you have these ideals and then
you're there to support and help people
i told you kelly i'm just kidding
okay
then your your working competencies are
invention and discernment these are my
strengths okay so you're okay with like
if you have to come up with new ideas
you do that yeah and discerning other
people's ideas you're good at that too
but if you didn't get to wonder and if
you didn't actually get to help people
and see people benefiting from your
stuff you'd wither actually and it's
it's amazing this thing pulls this out
uh it's when the big ideas come in and
james says okay we gotta turn this into
a segment and i'm like
right right right let's just sit around
and talk about it and he's like
we have to make a show right how are we
going to talk about this we need talking
points so we need to put in the prompt
and it's like uh how about we don't do
that you know exactly you're like hey
the fun part is done yeah we're done or
let's keep doing the fun part yes then
your your two working frustrations are g
and t this is interesting
making people do things that they don't
want to do oh is not fun
and then
then then like the dog at last details
of pushing things across the finish line
it's like the most of the good stuff
we have to keep going until it's
finished and i have to pursue that
that's not your thing patrick the last
month finished you finished a bunch of
books oh other people have to push me
you know those weeks when they're like
hey i need this list done and will you
check this citation
the font will you look um dude yeah yeah
it crushes us and and here's the deal
there are people in life you could flip
this upside down i know a woman who's
who's great at the things you know she's
like we're gonna finish and i'm gonna
make you do it and it brings her joy huh
joy and energy
exactly yeah yeah yeah that's kelly and
then and there are people so and what's
great about this is you know at the
highest level
this is about us that we don't judge
other people yeah or feel guilty about
ourselves we had a pastor call in and
say he had been feeling guilty about
being a pastor he thought he was bad
because he wasn't good at sermons coming
up with sermons and he knew so many
pastors that could go out and go for a
walk and come up with a great sermon he
did this he said i was a wonder i had no
wonder or invention in me oh wow
but what he was a great like counselor
he loved it to talk one-on-one with
people and he was and that's another
genius of a pastor but he wasn't the big
picture idea guy and he goes oh i don't
have to feel guilty about this anymore
i'm gonna i'm gonna borrow people and
they're gonna help me with that yes so
that was a huge relief
because we feel we go through life going
how come i'm not good at the stuff i'm
not good at cause you're not because god
didn't give you that gift so how do you
let's let's take that pastor for example
he may decide i might be better in a
different role here and it might mean
because the the head pastor makes more
money and the head pastors on on but it
might be for the sake of my sanity and
my biology and my marriage and my kids i
didn't take this role
how do you
teach somebody to say i know you've been
working to be a president
you're going to be the greatest number
two ever
like how do you teach somebody that
that's so interesting i i i honestly
believe so this this assessment takes
ten minutes to fill out i'm so enamored
by it it's incredible you get the
results back and people do it for
themselves the low-hanging fruit of this
people look at their things and go oh
crap i shouldn't be doing that
it's so convicting now but the good news
is this there's lots of different ways
to skin a cat and there's different ways
to run a company
so i'm an id yep i like to come up with
new ideas and discern the ideas i can
galvanize but i don't like to do it very
much i'm not bad at it
i still run my company yeah but i know
how to tap into somebody else's g so you
can actually be all different kinds of
ceos but you can't do all the activities
so i've had two the reason i had my
career in higher ed is i had two
different bosses the first one and then
the third one
they hired me and said we are the we're
the vice presidents we run this thing
i don't we don't do public facing things
we are behind the scenes
you will be oh you were perfect the fi
right and i like we will to make sure
the budgets are good that the hr stuff
is done all our people are taken care of
and loved but i need somebody out there
to and one boss i had asked me to go
through and i would text there's a group
of students here i need you to walk
through and they would walk out and
smile and that just it drained them but
they knew it was part of does that make
sense those are such incredible
self-aware leaders right because they
were filling the gap what a gift yeah
and so there's not really jobs where
you'd go
oh yeah i have to leave yeah um we had a
woman write to us after doing this and
she had her own staffing business and
she was ready to sell it she was so
burnt out and frustrated she took this
assessment and she goes oh my gosh i'm
spending all of my time doing the things
i hate
i can actually run this place and do the
things i love and and enable the people
around me to do the things they love she
reorganized stayed in the business it's
doing better she's loving what she's
doing so it's just about that awareness
and the humility to say i don't have to
be everything
here's can i tell you the magic part of
this yeah yeah yeah um i've spent the
last this has been especially convicting
um the last couple years just working on
the show i spent so long
working with academics working with
people who are who do wonder for a
living who are always thinking about
deep things trying to solve these
problems
and then you branch off of that into
i guess the nerd term now is the
biohackers these folks who have
resources and they've got this drive and
they want to take 98 and push it up to
the top one percent and they spend a
jillion dollars to do it and they'll go
get all this other help and support and
a coach for this and the coaches could
and coming here has realized made me
realize there's hundreds of millions of
people in this country just trying to
get through the day yeah and they are
absolutely left behind and then somebody
like you comes up with this thing that
takes 10 minutes
is incredibly inexpensive
and then you gave these you're such a
man such a great gift you gave all the
listeners here a discount on this thing
it's this is a kind of thing that can
change millions of people's lives we
priced it at 25 dollars what i'm saying
and there's a discount for for to make
it 18
with put ramsey in the code but it's um
we don't want anybody not to know who
they are that's what i mean yeah and if
you're like there's kids getting out of
college like i was but you know my job
when i got out of college that said was
the best job in america i would have had
to be an et to do that job well they're
my weaknesses yeah and if i'd known that
i'd have gone i i don't care if people
think this is the best job in america
i'm going to suck at it yeah or imagine
somebody taking this before they go to
college oh and like i want to major in
this or and maybe they decide not to go
to college because the things they want
to do they can already do that's exactly
right or a couple that is about to throw
in the towel or somebody's about to
respond to that text don't respond to it
get online and take this thing and sit
down with your spouse this gives you all
something to talk about when you all get
together once a month and just say how
checking in with each other right when i
look at a person i really help it's so
helpful to know what they love doing yes
and i have a son who's 15 i know it is
working geniuses i'm not going to parent
him the way i parented my other kids but
i didn't know that until last year and i
was like oh my gosh he's a wonderer
inventor
why do i think he's going to go and
drill on
algebra every day right if he gets a b
in algebra that's fine yeah you know so
man your kids won the lottery that's
awesome well so hey go to
workinggenius.com enter promo code
deloney d-e-l-o-n-y 25 off it's down 18
bucks 18 bucks to figure out who you are
it's incredible patrick thank you if
you're going to be here
you're like
i'm so glad you're moving here then we
can for real be best friends you don't
have to be my best friend but i'm yours
and dude you're just a wealth of
knowledge you're so generous since i'm
grateful for you
it's always it's always so much fun it's
awesome
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else buying a
home and my friends who refinance their
homes they tell me it makes them nuts
too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
suite 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
all right as we wrap up we always end
this show with
your favorite song ever
all right and you came prepared with
some lyrics i don't even know what they
are well they told me matt marr is a is
a christian singer who lives in
nashville now okay i don't even i don't
i've never heard the name well you know
his songs okay and everybody knows his
songs but he has a song called hold us
together okay and it's it's it's a great
song it's one of those great songs very
cool check it out okay so
as we wrap up the music will fade up
they'll fade up the music read the read
the lyrics here it don't have a job
won't pay your bills it won't buy you a
home in beverly hills it won't fix your
life in five easy steps ain't the law of
the land or the government but it's all
you need and love will hold us together
wow
that's what it is i'll repeat that love
will hold us together i love it my man
hey patrick thank you so much man you
made my whole year thank you so much
thank you take care we'll see you soon
on the dr john de luna show